OK, let's get into audience questions for
the week. David, now, with more hindsight,
can we finally say what George W. Bush's
legacy is and how does it compare to what
you thought it would be when he left office?
This is a really interesting question. I actually
see George W. Bush's legacy now, many years out
from his presidency, as exactly what I believed it
would be when George W. Bush left office. Now,
you could make the case. It just hasn't been
enough time. We need to wait even more time to
know what George W. Bush's real long term legacy
is going to be, but sort of around the edges
from the point of view of of tone rather than
substance. George W. Bush was known for being sort
of the dumb president, not particularly bright.
I think the Trump presidency has put that in
context, like at least George W. Bush read books.
You know, he was dumb ish, but
not as dumb as Donald Trump
on policy and failures of George W. Bush's
legacy when he left office was that of
a war criminal who went to war with the wrong
country after the 9/11 attacks, invading Iraq
and starting the disaster that we now know of and
even have much agreement on from many Republicans
as to that war. Also in the post 9/11 era, George
W. Bush's legacy is the Patriot Act and the sort
of start of a progressive set, not progressive
politically, but a growing and advancing set of
restrictions on privacy of many kinds, including
via technological means. The failure on Katrina,
certainly Hurricane Katrina, one of the
main legacy elements of George W. Bush.
And that's really what we believed when George W.
Bush left office. And this is interesting from the
standpoint of being able to tell versus not being
able to tell legacy relatively quickly. I mean,
I think the question would be if you went back
to FDR, did we know FDR, his legacy, right. When
when he was no longer in office? I think looking
at the contemporaneous writing you sort of did,
getting the U.S. and the world beyond World
War two and the New Deal that that was widely
written about at the time and I would argue is
still the bulk of FDR legacy. Abraham Lincoln,
you go back to Abraham Lincoln and, quote, freeing
the slaves, being part of the union around Civil
War times. I don't know if the term legacy was
being used at the time of Lincoln's assassination,
but certainly it was clear that that was a big
deal. Not everybody liked it, but that that was
a big deal. So I do think that the benefit of
hindsight is useful in thinking about what is
the legacy of a president and the more distance
you get from it, the more important and useful
that that can be. But with George W. Bush, at
least the his legacy was pretty clear right away.
And now, as we are 13 years out from George
W. Bush, it has remained that way. Now,
if there are things I'm missing that you think
are part of George W. Bush's legacy, let me know.
And then the question becomes, what is Donald
Trump's legacy going to be? And not good,
I think is how I would characterize it. But we'll
leave the deeper analysis for another moment.